now we have a big problem in this
country let me get to our first guest
joining us Professor Alan Dershowitz of
Harvard you know professor you and I
have a common bond a love of Israel and
what has now come out on multiple
occasions should outrage every American
and the fact that the Democratic Party
could not take a stand and named this
woman and condemn this and keep her on
the committee to me is outrageous I
agree with you and I think that these
Democrats the ones on the extreme left
are trying to turn the Democratic Party
into Britain's a Labour Party headed by
an overt anti-semite like korben korben
makes the same argument so it wasn't
anti-semitic it was just anti Zionist
but what Omar said is clearly
anti-semitic and she should have been
condemned my name singled out
anti-semitism should have been isolated
as the real problem that were
confronting not only in this country but
around the world but the Democrats by
watering it down it was as if you know
after the black children were killed in
in Alabama back in the civil rights
movement and somebody wanted to
introduce a resolution condemning
attacks on black children some
southerners said oh yeah yeah yeah but
let's also include attacks on white
children no that's not the way you do it
you look at the problem the problem is
anti-semitism coming from Omar and
others like her and that has to be
condemned and that has to be condemned
uniquely and singularly and strongly I'm
worried about the rise of anti-semitism
in Europe these insane white supremacist
groups they're rearing their ugly head I
don't care where it comes from it needs
to be confronted and and and stopped and
called out and I thought this was an act
of cowardice this week I really did it
was disgraceful look look you know what
else is an act of cowardice because
Democrats and others and people on the
Left won't condemn black lives matter
black lives matter in their platform so
do we want web cops
Israel calls it genocide --all calls it
apartheid and look I care about black
lives I've devoted my life to protecting
black lives but I will not support the
organization black lives matter because
I have zero tolerance for anti-semitism
zero tolerance for anti-catholicism zero
tolerance for anti Muslim zero tolerance
for any kind of bigotry you cannot
create that that group has said what do
we want dead cops what do we want them
now we have that on tape pigs in a
blanket fry them like Baker I've got to
move on though let me ask you about Adam
Schiff and professor this one bit of
testimony of Bruce or is showing many
lies and contradictions this is just the
beginning we're going to see the FISA
warrants we're going to see the 302s
we're going to see the gang of eight
information and we're gonna get all of
these all the testimony of all of these
people and what we learn is we should
see everything mm-hmm okay but what
bothers me in all transparency is the
essence yeah yeah we now know that many
people here lighting under oath what do
you think of Adam Schiff what did you
think of that tape with him thinking
he's talking to a Russian what do you
think of his staff spending ten hours
with Michael Kohn well we now know that
the allegations in the steel dossier
aren't even supported by steel I think
that FISA Court or to consider holding
in contempt contempt of court people who
submitted the FISA application while
withholding relevant information that
might have led them to a different
conclusion look you know we live in such
a strange time the other headline is
Jesse smolens getting indicted
thankfully it's very important anybody
who falsely accuses anybody should be
called to task I've been falsely accused
as fortunately I was able to disprove
the allegations but the people who
accuse me should be prosecuted and
should be investigated nobody should be
able to make false accusations and get
away with it I've lived with that my
whole career and the standard is so
hi even you and an army of Alan
Dershowitz as couldn't win a case I am
glad about this this young these
Covington kids they have a great lawyer
in Lynwood and what happened in his case
was a disgrace all right I want to
remind everybody you are going to write
an introductory response to the Muller
report that's right and that will be
coming out it will be out just days
after just days after the motor report
becomes public I'm working with a very
very fast publisher a sky horse they
will be the first ones out with the
report with my introduction all right
professor thank you for being with us
tonight